[Applause]
anthony davis fakes now
scoots it you see the strength of pj
tucker
james settles for the jumper and knocks
that one down
james puts his head down drives inside
stops kicks it back out caldwell pulp is
open
that one way off rebound anthony davis
take advantage of the ability to
offensive rebound
anthony davis pursues the basketball
gets the easy
land five years out of the nba and on
that journey that you spoke of
changed him when he came back as anthony
davis throws that up
james getting his first breather anthony
davis very aggressive early goes right
at
pj tucker once again using his size
count it and one
i like the way that he's aggressive this
is a good defense by pj tucker but he's
going towards the hoop so he gets better
position
high percentage basically harden has one
and a half guys defending him
martin just trying to draw a foul there
caldwell pope comes the other way
lay up bank shots good again good ball
movement
covington bad pass
cross court intercepted by rondo james
fakes the pass
left-handed lamb
[Applause]
rondo gonna try a three knocks it down
rajan rondo
at the buzzer floor is a good three
[Applause]
just remarkable james spins gets inside
layup is good we talked about it in the
open this is what we have to see from
lebron james
putting his head down and making plays
no big man on the floor for the houston
rockets
make him pay the price good move by
their man looked like a zone he said
he was getting compliments from other
coaches hey that's a great zone you have
he's like no no it was the man caruso up
and james down
he was getting compliments from other
coaches hey that's a great zone you have
he's like no no it was the man caruso up
and james down
is causing turnover problems for houston
and then
this is where the lakers are great in
transition
steel one pass
and an easy love to the fly waiters did
not play in game one
getting some early minutes here in game
two westbrook really struggling that's
another turnover
caruso off the floor caruso
up the floor james now
joins his teammates just in time all
perfect pass
look at the play by lebron james a
little touch pass
beautiful simple basketball but the
vision
and morris stella first half but he's
benefited from two of the best
lovable personality and early in his
career and this is his sixth nba team
he's one of the better shot blockers in
the game danny green knocks down the
three
davis huge height advantage and he is
unstoppable here in the first half now
six of eight from the field
well daniel house tries to take away the
middle
davis loves going left
and analytically catch so he catches the
basketball and gives himself a chance
boy that's a tough shot danny green with
his second long distance bomb
back to 12. that's seven assists for
rondo in his first half
oh shot swatted away
russell westbrook one for seven
james draws the foul count it at one
in this movie before lebron james using
grown man strength
with the big time finish period
[Applause]
17th year in the league
[Applause]
in the year we're during a regular
season so far in the playoffs and this
is his fifth game he's two for 14 from
three point range
caldwell pulp sinks one from deep in the
corner and lee
back up to 18. well they just throw it
to anthony davis covington commits to
the steal which
leaves look much better here in his
second game back james way outside with
the three-point
say it said it time and time again when
eric gordon is healthy
boy he is a terrific player davis gets
inside
and finishes jeff green took a shot
rockets have scored 14 straight points
they were down by as many as 21 in the
first half
davis counted and the foul davis does on
the other end
no time to mess around i'm going to
punish the smaller defenders
championship with clint capela in the
middle they are a different team in a
championship
contest as hard as you can without
fouling or appearing to foul
and you got to live with the results
james to kuzma
kyle kuzma from downtown nine points now
for kuzma
this year doesn't mean anything this is
a situation unto itself
davis hits that one stay disciplined and
true
and not trying to do too much davis
without the ball james found him easily
and not trying to do too much
davis two second difference between shot
clock and game clock
five on the 24. james head down drives
an easy layup for lebron james
lebron james last possession realizes
westbrook defending him puts his head
down attacks the paint
area easy laying round two trying to
even the series
after dropping game one james drives
down
lane and finishes strong lebron
james with authority and the game is
tied help wise
in the previous play if you don't rotate
on time
gordon lost the handle picked up by
james back to caruso throws it up
hammer time for lebron james
i mean the steal mike bring calling for
hammer time
lakers regain the lead up four
westbrook eight on the 24.
little shake and bake swatted out of
bounds by james
the corner pass and gets back into the
pitcher
that's outstanding effort by james
daniel house has to get it up
shot misses james with his 10th rebound
finds caruso cunning and caruso
finishing for davis
davis has tucker on him step back foul
on jumpers
that series tied at one game apiece
they'll have game three tomorrow night
on tnt now shot blocked by james
this pass inside danny green green
turn shoots misses davis right there on
the following
long rebound danny green tips at caruso
trying to save it looks for someone to
throw it too
and the ball winds up in danny green's
hands davis fakes drives laughs
banks davis now with 34 and the lead is
a dozen for the lakers
shot clock at five anthony davis double
team finds james james spins puts it up
puts it in lebron james i've anthony
davis
double team finds james james spins puts
it up
puts it in guys showed up and showed out
anthony davis and lebron james moving
without the basketball